Hey guys for this video. I'm going to show you how to make [one] of my easiest desktop weapons yet
The mini RPG the materials for this product are so simple you may already have them lying around the house
You're just going to need some drinking straws a hot glue gun a pair of scissors and some of these pop snaps
Now the length of your drinking straw could be measured very easily by using some Lego blocks
I put them together in this pattern so we're six studs
Deep if you line your straw up and hold it with one finger
You can very easily cut off the end and we're going to be building some fins as well
We're going to need to make four cuts along the lines of the straw two studs deep
Now these don't have to be super precise
All you need are basically four flaps that will fold upward and form a cross like this
But they have a natural tendency to fold back and take the shape of the straw in so we need to heat treat them with
Something like a barbecue lighter
All you need to do is slowly lower from the top until you see the fins start to move downward
Then push your thumb up there and hold it for about three seconds
The heat helps reform the plastic and makes the fins very very springy now you probably know that these pockets come encased in
sawdust
that's because these little things are impact sensitive when they hit the ground they explode and that's because all they are are little bits of
Gravel covered with fulminated Mercury, which is a contact explosive
Spread your pop snaps on the table and give the sawdust a little blow
the inside of our straw is hollow and the pop snaps have these little streams that pop off the top so I like to put
Them down inside, and then just use a couple dabs of hot glue to secure them in place
Now they're fun to use like this you could just throw them like darts, and they will explode
But just to power things up a little bit
I went to the gas station and picked up a whole handful of straws now these straws
Come in all different sizes shapes and varieties
I found the bigger ones that are used for soda or pretty well
And here's how they work take your fins of your RPG and tuck [them] back into a straw shape and then slowly push them into
The end of the one of the straws so it tucks in nicely like that
These micro rPGs are only intended to be shot at little paper Targets and at my house
There's nothing scary than a Minecraft zombie or a creeper, so let's put them to the test
The coolest thing about these cartridges is they're reusable so after you snap one off
Go ahead and pull out the hot glue
Grab a new snap it add a little more hot glue to that reload it the exact same way
And while a straw is functional. It's not very cool. So let's power up once again to make a bona fide RPG launcher like this
Start at one Edge and gently roll the straw until it touches the entire strip of duct tape roll
It slowly and evenly just like that
We've got a digital camo Rocket launch or Tube
And if we snip the ends we can clean it up and make it look super professional
Next I'm going to use a little bit of electrical tape for aesthetics
We're going to put a strip of electrical tape on both ends
And then a couple more in the middle just for decoration and this one is going to be quite a bit thicker
That's just going to give us a little bit more of a 3D effect
So when I was at the gas station I also found these very small clear tubes
and if we take a strip of duct tape and wrap it around the clear Tube we can instantly turn it black and then with
A bit of an angled cut we can make the optical scope look pretty cool
While that's cooling, we can move on to making our handles and for that
I'm just using a popsicle stick and a sharpie marker then we're going to cut off the tip I'd say about half an inch
Cut it up the middle
We color the center of it with the sharpie that will complete the handle for us
Once you press that in flip it over make sure everything's lined up symmetrically so that when it's upside down
It should look like a little shark fin with the scope hanging directly below it
So these things work exactly like they did before because it's literally the same straw just pinch the fins
Push it down into the rocket launcher Tube until the warhead rests against the tip now just grab the handles
Place it in your mouth [and] give it a quick burst of air
Now these things are pretty fun
but if you want to go to the extreme, you can get some of these
These are the adult version of Snappers and they contain ten times as much fulminated Mercury which means a much bigger explosion
These things load
Exactly the same way a little hot glue the straw goes on and the cool thing is they [are] the exact width that you need
To fit into one of these straws you can rest that flush, and they shoot out exactly the same way with a lot bigger bang
Wow, that's pretty cute
So there you have it guys the mini RPG an awesome project done with very simple materials someone that you can try it
Thanks for joining me for this project. I'll be looking for you the next one. Talk to you then
Nailed it!
That was unexpected
*Laughter*